ils sont les parents de romane
protasiewicz et se morfondent jour et
nuit depuis dimanche sauver mon fils
déplore sa mère natalia aux leaders du
monde entier
vous avez dit elle en images et en photo
ce que le régime de loukachenko
c'est aux jeunes qui comme mon fils se
battre pour la liberté la démocratie le
couple est convaincu que romana déjà été
torturé cette vidéo publiée par le
régime de loukachenko au lendemain de
son arrestation lundi le montre en
prison il dit qu'il est bien traité mais
ses parents et collègues affirment
qu'ils les maquis pour couvrir des bleus
au visage
depuis le monde est sans nouvelles de
lui mais la riposte des pays de l'europe
et sans équivoque le boycott de l'espace
aérien du bélarus est entrée en vigueur
nous allons droit à une escale à la
réaction européenne était sauf que le
soutien de la russie à loukachenko
s'invite aussi dans le ciel en moins de
24 heures trois vols d'air france et de
la compagnie austrian à destination de
moscou ont dû être annulées parce que la
russie refusent qu'il contourne le
bélarus le signal inquiétant d'une
analyse de constantine qui a donné à le
pouvoir de décision sur les relations
entre la liste européenne des créateurs
extrêmement irresponsables nous le
plaidoyer de l'opposition en exil
d'aller encore plus loin et de couper
les vivres en frappant les industrie
lucrative de la potasse et du pétrole au
bélarus
or depuis qu'il a démissionné du
gouvernement de loukachenko
l'ex-député anatole qatar vie en pologne
tout comme les parents de romane
protasiewicz qui se croyaient à l'abri
des horreurs du régime
chaque jour compte pour les prisonniers
politiques a dit natalia avant de
s'adresser directement à son fils
du reste fort nous t'aimons et nous te
sortir au delà
la suite va se jouer ici demain quand le
cac chaîne coût sera reçu par vladimir
poutine
une alliance inconfortable mais
nécessaire pour les ambitions de la
russie mais maintenant soutien au
bélarus dans les circonstances est un
affront à l'europe est une autre
provocation et si thammarat alter escaut
radio-canada moscou